[Music]
he's stepping up to the plate
to save the golden state on september
14th
california will hold a special election
to recall governor gavin newsom
among the 24 gop candidates campaigning
to replace him
is my next guest he's the new york times
bestselling author and
host of the nationally syndicated radio
program the larry elder show
joining me now somebody named larry
elder
how you doing greg i'm good how are you
thank you for having me all right i got
my first question is are you crazy
i mean california is california
salvageable is it salvageable
i really think it is the you know the
legislatures are dominated by super
majorities in the senate and the
assembly
but the governor has a lot of power even
dealing with the hostile legislature
including the power to declare a
statewide emergency i have a line item
veto
i have the ability to appoint the
commissioners and people to the public
utility commission
i also have that big thing known as the
bully pulpit so there are a lot of
things that i can do
it's not hopeless we're talking about
crime we're talking about rising cost of
living we're talking about
the outrageous homelessness and the way
this man has ignored science while his
own kids were enjoying
in-person private education while
shutting down schools for kids already
behind
we have among the lowest scores in
california and
75 percent of black boys before the
coronavirus pandemic rape
could not read at state levels of
proficiency and that was before the
pandemic
almost half of all third graders cannot
i support choice in public education
teachers union adamantly opposed to that
and guess who's the largest funder
of my opponent the teachers union of
course yeah and if you talk i mean the
the the sad thing about education i mean
if you tackled education
all the other problems get solved right
i mean basically you
you you absolutely crime homeless all
that stuff is somehow
linked to that those first years of life
where essentially
we have handed over that period of life
to an elite class of activists and
unionists
essentially right well that's right my
high schools crenshaw high school if you
saw the movie boys in the hood
that's my high school only two percent
of kids are math proficient
now the inner city parents polls show
black and brown parents
want the ability to say uh i want to put
my kid into a charter school
a private school or religious school and
again the teachers union are adamantly
opposed to that
and when you look at where teachers pull
their own school-age kids greg
they're far more likely to have their
own kids in private school than
households that don't have public school
teachers the people that know the school
system the best
aren't putting their own kids in them
you know i want to talk to you about the
homeless situation because it's the most
obvious thing that you see whenever you
land in la or san francisco
these this is not the way people
envision homelessness as like oh this
family was thrown out of their house or
it was a homeless veteran
these are people that come with tents
and they live
they just live on the street a lot of
them are healthy a lot of them are
mentally
ill but they refuse to leave and they
have people on their side they have an
act again an elite activist class that
is there
protecting them how do you get what
would you do
well that's right what the what the what
the governor does and what the lawmakers
do in sacramento
is have what i call a housing first
policy and that is to build homes and
far more far more expensively
than the private sector would do without
dealing with the underlying reason why
people are on the streets
majority of them are mentally ill and
have substance abuse problems
those need to be dealt with there's all
sorts of treatment centers we have all
sorts of money for that
and then you need to have low cost
housing so to the extent that you can
get some of them
off the street where are they going to
go the average price of a home in
california is 150
more than the average price of a home in
america and because of the rules and
regulations and the environmental
extremists the average price of a home
in california
is literally 50 more than otherwise
would be so
in other words you need to suspend some
of the rules and regulations that are
causing the private sector not to build
low-cost housing we need to get the
churches involved
religious organizations involved in
counseling people and getting them to
become self-sufficient and then this
problem over time can be solved
what how do you feel about running
against caitlyn jenner
how do you do we know how you defer in
some ways but politically
well greg i want to take a punt on that
one because this is a two-step deal
right unless 50 plus one california vote
to recall gavin newsom
it doesn't matter how well the
republicans do i'm way ahead of the
other republicans i've raised way more
money than all but one of them who can
sell fund
so i'm not worried about the republican
side i just want people to remember why
2.2 million people
signed their petition a good quarter of
them are independents and democrats who
want this guy out for all the reasons
that i just now mentioned
what do you think his chances are of
being recalled because i just saw a poll
now that looks like it could happen but
then
everybody i know there was that's this
is just he's he's safe what do you
what do you think i think he's in
serious trouble and he knows it
the the the polls are right in the
margin of error about half of them want
him gone
about half of them don't and 53 even if
they don't want him gone don't want him
to have another four-year term
so he is in trouble no matter what and i
think and i know that he's worried about
me that's why i'm urging people great to
go to
elder.com throw a little something in
the tip jar because he can raise
and spend an unlimited amount of money
one teacher's union just gave him 1.8
million
and shortly after it was obvious i was
going to run the service employees union
gave him 5 million
it looks like he's going to spend
anywhere from 50 to 75 million dollars
to defeat me so i need people
inside california and outside california
to help me by going to elect elder.com
awesome well thanks larry thanks for
joining us best of luck i'm from
california
it's not the place i grew up in probably
probably not even close at this point
i don't even i don't even go there
anymore but anyway i hope to one day
return
thanks larry all right up next
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else